le pitch du service après vente des
émissions si les téléspectateurs qui
appellent pour donner leur avis ou se
plaindre des émissions il dirait quoi 6
appelé pour parler de ce monde en parle
à votre avis on peut écouter mais il
faudrait se mettre en condition de
service après vente
il faudrait les téléphones ouais ouais
parce que quelqu'un des téléphones a
indiqué le canton étaient piégées
avaient déjà tout prévu a eu d'accord
attention hein
un service après vente des émissions
bonjour oui bonjour monsieur oui je vous
appelle la propos d'eva
vas-y gauvin valeska valeska we have à
venir dans tout le monde parle oui alors
qui est cette personne
bah écoutez elle a joué dans la ferme
alors elle a fait quel animal elle a
fait la poule où la [ __ ] comment
écouter non c'est oui
voilà
j'appelle tu appelles j'appelle pour
tout service après vente des émissions
bonjour oui bonjour je vous appelle par
rapport à tout le monde en parle et donc
que la tôle ont dit thierry ardisson
l'extraordinaire je suis désolé mais moi
personnellement je trouve que c'est
vraiment un gros bond il pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux